[Music]
on the ground as troops fight bombs fall
and people flee from the terror this
looks very much like a war between
ukraine and russian invaders
but something else is happening here too
for while europe and the us have refused
to fight militarily or impose a no-fly
zone they are already at economic war
with russia
we have purposely designed these
sanctions to maximize the long-term
impact on russia these sanctions will
suppress russia's economic growth we
will continue on a remorseless mission
to squeeze russia from the global
economy piece by piece
this
is a financial battle one that could
change the very nature of the world
economy an invisible assault that goes
further than anything we've ever seen
before
this is something we did not do in world
war ii with germany that really is a new
use of financial power that's quite
unprecedented i'm definitely worried yes
it's worth just taking a step back and
considering the scale and the speed of
what we're talking about here in terms
of sanctions from america and europe
you've got financial sanctions on
individuals oligarchs politicians we've
had them before but they've gone even
further you've got the financial
messaging network swift russia's been
cut off from it it makes it even more
difficult to get money in and out and
then you've got trades new tariffs on
goods coming out of russia effectively
it is a pariah in the global trading
system and all of this has happened very
quickly because when it comes to
economic war
speed matters
this was an attempt by europe and the
united states to tilt the battlefield in
ukraine's favor and i still think to a
degree that is the way in which we're
thinking about these measures is a sort
of siege against russia a counter siege
of an economic financial trade tech
variety to try and alter the outcome in
military terms of a struggle which is
not resolved
and the list of measures go on we've
seen companies going beyond the rules
pulling out of russia even when they
don't need to like mcdonald's and visa
and mercedes there's a ban on selling
any product of russia with american
technology in it which means it's
essentially cut off from the most
advanced computer tech
and then there's the final punishment
perhaps the biggest which comes down to
what many in russia saw as their
financial trump card reserves
reserves are essentially a pile of money
or gold that countries set aside as an
insurance policy and russia has an awful
lot of them it's supposed to buy you
time in the event of a financial crisis
but here's the thing a lot of those
reserves are not in moscow but actually
in european countries in paris and in
frankfurt and in london and when these
financial sanctions were imposed europe
and the u.s said no you don't
we're gonna
cut you off
i don't think that anyone has frozen
central bank reserves in the way that
western countries have with russia's
reserves and so that really is a new
use of financial power that's quite
unprecedented
the upshot in the following days a
collapse in the russian currency the
ruble it's unclear whether russia will
be able to pay any of its foreign
currency debt in the coming months not
because it doesn't have the money
because it's not allowed to use the
money a default but not as we know it
that brings us to the impact and in
short it could be very bad for russia a
cataclysmic recession perhaps even worse
than in ukraine raising the question was
that the plan if this is economic war
what constitutes victory
the battle could be we want to weaken
the russian economy to the point that
it's either unable to be a danger and
or um
keep making sure that it's unable to
perform these actions again in the
future so there is indeed a war logic
being applied
the impact elsewhere around the world
will also be severe we could see a food
crisis especially in sub-saharan africa
which is enormously reliant on russian
and ukrainian wheat
russia and ukraine altogether account
for about 30 percent of wheat export as
you know fertilizers as well so
cutting this production off for a number
of countries will have two impacts one
is that we are seeing global pricings
rising
uh and the other one is that some of the
sweets and some countries really needed
it badly and then there's energy russia
has the world's biggest reserves of
natural gas europe massively reliant on
it and you might have thought that would
have gone down since the invasion but
have a look at this
actually since the invasion flows of
natural gas from russia to europe have
gone up to the highest level so far this
year in other words even as europe
imposes sanctions on russia it is also
funneling billions of euros of cash
across to russia to finance energy
if you're involved in a long protracted
siege of russia you have to pace
yourself i mean this is the position of
the german government right we precisely
because we're serious about this we need
to move in a deliberate fashion
in other words there is real politic
pragmatism going on here even amid the
economic war but for germany and the
rest this conflict is likely to do
something else redraw the map
for decades germany practiced aust
politic trying to draw russia closer to
europe through economic and energy ties
but now in the face of economic war does
russia lean to the east towards india
towards china and are western nations
redouble their alliance and does all of
that constitute a new cold war i do
think the world is going to be different
because
i think that the degree of risk that
people have
recognized
a strategic risk that exists in the
world is not going to go away
even if in the short run the russians
are forced to to back down
and that has a lot of consequences for
the way we regard globalized trade and
our dependence on other countries
in other words this may only be the
start of a bigger economic war with
bigger consequences
globalization the way the world fits
together has long been at a crossroads
is this the moment it heads down a
different path altogether
you